pretending to be a cop that's easy you
drive around pull people over for going
52 into 15 just be like all right you
hanged up wait for your ticket I'm gonna
be back to [ __ ] you in a sec look be
cool don't speak cop stars these two
guys one of which I can't really think
of what he's in the other is Damon
Wayans kid I call that dude Damon Wayans
a shows like the guys like the great
beat Damon Wayans
turns out he's Damon Wayans Jr like
actually Damon Wayans Jr that made sense
I guess Damon Wayans Jr over here he's
in a dead-end job it doesn't get any
respect he works for this really shitty
video game developing company otherwise
known as EA the other dude doesn't do
much of anything at all I live in LA
neither of them really like LA because
there are two normal guys in a land of
evil snakes and Leatherface monsters
that feed off of the broken dreams of
other human beings but one day they go
to this costume party dressed as cops
like legit cop outfits and people
actually think they're cops and you're
like wait people think we're cops it's
kind of fun so let's just keep doing
that so we can have a movie when I saw
the trailer for this movie I was like
this is the most hilarious premise ever
and it actually still is a really
hilarious premise was this movie
hilarious the premise is interesting
funny it's really funny when they first
start doing this because like guys are
skateboarding they're like freeze and
I'll tumble off a skateboard
just tell people to stop and dishes
seeing that they have that kind of power
based on what they're wearing is really
cool to say feel like they're a kid in a
candy store like they're a little kid in
Wonka's factory they're like holy [ __ ]
this world has opened up to us what
would you do in that situation I'd mess
with people don't know what that says
about the quality of my character but I
would mess with people if people thought
I was actually a cop be a great ride
right before I went to jail the villain
in this movie I called them evil Ethan
Hawke like seriously he's like if Ethan
Hawke and training day actually went
through the whole thing went through
with it killed Alonso Harrison took it
over so I'm nice and you know what boom
I'm on the dark side on him evil Ethan
Hawke that's what it looks what he done
but the pacing of this movie in the
timing of the humor is all just sloppy
nothing really made me die alive and
there was no gut-busting laughing that I
didn't is move in different chuckles
periodically sporadically a lot of times
of white noise though you're watching
you're like yeah I appreciate it I do
but is it hilarious am I gonna sit here
and be like guys you should pay at least
11 bucks a person to see this movie oh
this movie was like the lovechild of
blue streak and cop-out and I know I'm
really hard on comedies because when I
watch a comedy I like to laugh a lot I
don't like to watch a comedy and laugh a
couple times and say that's good enough
for me
let's be cops you're not gonna remember
it in t minus a day yeah I've already
forgotten you will too
I don't know so hard about being a cop
these days lot don't want paperwork it's
good weird good and guys if you haven't
checked out my Aladdin review in honor
of Robin Williams please check that out
all the money that video makes from
Google Adsense from your guys's views I
will donate the anxiety and depression
Association of America all you dick bags
out there who are like ok so no one
cares until a celebrity dies and people
care whatever at least people trying out
dick for those of you who've been
circulating the video and helping the
cause thank you check out that video
please circulate it around let me give a
lot to that cause so if you guys could
fake being cops what would you do
whatever you do comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more